der letzte gegner und wir sind mega gut
ausgestattet wir können ihn holen können
wir überraschen kriegt überhaupt mit
dass weder card com soll er hat mein
bett service sg jetzt herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen video
ich hoffe wir heute bis er einen schönen
tag und ja ich begrüße ich ganz herzlich
so folger maßen ich muss aber sagen ich
habe mich vor langer langer zeit das
erste mal dafür interessiert ein
bisschen mehr verantwortung zu
übernehmen so auf den ganzen microsoft
server nicht fand es eigentlich immer
schon cool du bist hier nach für recht
und ordnung zu sorgen nach dem rechten
zu schauen und darauf zu achten dass die
am morgen gewarnt wird dass die spieler
respektvoll miteinander umgehen dass
niemand gegen regeln verstößt niemand
hektar und so weiter und so fort
deswegen habe ich vor knapp drei wochen
war es oder so
drei wochen zehnte zehnter märz habe ich
eine bewerbung losgeschickt an das team
von goma hd und abgefragt ob es
eventuell möglich wäre dass sie mich in
das motti mit aufnehmen und jetzt kann
ich verkünden
das ist tatsächlich so weit ist guckt
euch das hier an der rote name ist da
und ich wurde aufgenommen ins team
mein größter wunsch ist in erfüllung
gegangen aber stichwort wunsch leute ihr
habt euch auch was wünschen dürfen
anlässlich der 30.000 abos diese
geknackt haben jüngst eine sehr nette
zahl habe mich da durchaus darüber
gefreut dass gesehen habe habe ich
gesagt wir machen ein kleines loch kann
das wunschkonzert und ihr habt die
möglichkeit mal zu entscheiden welches
spiel modus gespielt wird ich habe uns
durch paul eröffnet
ihr habt abgestimmt und das ergebnis ist
blieb aber weil bleiben ob der mann
überhaupt nicht sehen kann sind wir
jetzt hier aufgrund nehmen die zweite
option war und zwar spielen wir jetzt
beide ohren liegt
dort sagt bloss eine einsame einsame
jahr über nach mainz sehr schön nochmal
so alles klar einer metapher oder als
letzter auf jeden fall so viele youtube
so viel youtube
was ist das für eine runde was ist
eigentlich ein grüner ein def spongebob
ag ein mod ob jetzt da muss ich musste
schon die aktivitäten besser gestellten
darum das kann jetzt nicht gebrauchen so
schön ein bisschen hinten dran mehr da
aber wir können es trotzdem noch
schaffen kann es trotzdem noch schaffen
wir sind gerade mal drei sekunden in
dieser runde aber wir können trotzdem
noch schaffen was man für eine scheiße
manchmal aber okay egal jetzt abnehmen
kann man ja nicht platzieren das ist
überhaupt kein problem so sehr schön bei
uns bisschen schräg in die mitte über
alter mann habe ich das letzte mal eine
1a hundebett rausgespielt 8 mal 1 das
muss in einem livestream gewesen sein
aber wie lange her wie lange her
die um mio so da kommt doch keiner zu
mir rüber dass wagen sie nicht ein
bisschen im mittel oder nicht
oder doch ein bisschen hier noch passt
so weit ich haben schon versprochen wir
haben tatsächlich die 30.000 jetzt
geklagt
es geht nach wie vor steil nach oben und
ja es macht einfach spaß der ganzen
geschichte so zuzuschauen zu sehen wie
sich das entwickelt
zu sehen dass jo ok hast du ja mit mir
kommen
alles klar gut einfach so zu sehen dass
die ganze arbeit die man reinsteckt sich
auch irgendwann auszahlt das aber so
sagt man gutes gefühl
hallo egal was mit ihm los
ok alles klar egal jetzt hat es hat
nicht gereicht ok reagieren was ist los
man das nicht mehr normal
natürlich hab ich hier getötet nee ich
schon vor einem jahr töten können wenn
das zuhörer nicht ist der server oder es
ist der einzelne typ p diamanten schon
rüstung ich muss jetzt ganz ganz ganz
gaststätte okay so dann passt das
eigentlich ganz gut
wer jetzt noch keiner der mitte ist ja
sieht ganz aus wenn auch keiner da okay
diana schalten sich auch schon aus also
sind schon zwei teams raus das ist gut
so der goldregen der goldregen kommt
genau an den zeitpunkt nämlich hier
ankomme sehr schön wunderbar 26 gold
nehme ich mit dann gehe ich alle gaza
und na jetzt wieder andere mit der henne
ei problem
hat den bogen weiter geschlagen da oder
auf jeden fall erstmal ihr so die
klinikchefs paid holen kommt der
übernahme kommt nicht vor der kirche
alles da ich werds bisschen ein bisschen
hektik weil ich hab da würde jetzt
sofort darüber stürmen pink ist auch
schon raus alter die runde geht richtig
schnell sehr schön
ok restliche rüstung alles gut so weit
es geht mir ist klar dass ich glaube
meine taktik wird jetzt sein dass ich
meine ender perle holender perle stärke
trank und ein geschwindigkeits trank und
dann werde ich einfach hier versuchen
alles zu rasieren
zum beispiel den da drüben weist die
frage komme ich darüber so schnell auf
wie vor hohem bogen gucken wie viel
kosten stärker tage 7 okay da kann ich
mir noch mal umgebogen wollen es reicht
eine rettungsplattform bräuchte ich
eigentlich auch ich weiß nicht
rettungsplattform holen oder ein bogen
ich glaube ich und mir lieber einen
bogen
das ist besser gerade komme ja da drüben
kommt um die ecke gebogen wechsel hatten
ok
fast soweit gute pigs schwer bräuchte
ich auch noch her komme ich nur noch
kleine schwert leyen hier alles klar so
heftig aber direkt runter geiler typ ich
habe mir noch kurzen kleinen speed rang
und dann kann der ganze spaß auch schon
los gehen erstmal noch paar blöcke und
rein die ender perle parat
und dann packen wir das jetzt hier
kommen als aller erstes mal auf den
grünen da drüben war ich wahrscheinlich
für den gar nicht die ender bälle
braucht egal was er war trotzdem erst
mal sehen was so alles klar bloß nicht
runterfallen grad richtig panische angst
irgendwie ganz dumm runterzufallen blau
ist auch schon raus und ich wohne jetzt
gleich grün
was macht er da was macht der typ der
hat er irgendwie keiner verbaut sich da
ein
was ist das denn für eine taktik ok
kannst du kannst unter fliegen kannst du
fliegen ja ganz nett wäre ganz nett von
dir sehr schön okay dann nutze ich die
gelegenheit wahr um den gästen war hier
gerade ein bisschen abzubauen
noch heute gibt er mir so hat der kommt
flieg flieg flieg flieg jetzt fliegt weg
sehr schön ok reicht das schon
ich glaube das könnte reichen ja das
reicht meist ohne es direkt raus perfekt
am nt schöne runde
dahinten gelb auch schon bei kokain hat
er denn schon rausgeworfen
warum hat er sich gerade hier eingebaut
das weiß auch wirklich niemand egal soll
mich nicht stören soll mich nicht weiter
stören vielleicht sollte ich die ränder
perle lieber auf den hotkey packen
ich weiß es nicht ich weiß es nicht egal
machen das so jetzt ohne hotkey ich
fahre immer runter ich war immer
untereinander games an den dünnsten
stellen zu den dümmsten zeitpunkt nur
noch ein gegner alter krass okay das ist
eine richtig schnelle runde glaube ich
das dürfte eine richtigstellung knackige
runde werden wir können jetzt unsere
ender perle wie candy einsetzen
wir können uns den vorteil ausspielen
dieses ass im ärmel was wir haben können
wir einsetzen
alter schwede der übertreibt wie viel
schlaf okay es aber da hinten glaube
aber wie kommt man zu dem rüber egal ich
letztes mal dass die ganzen ganzen
goldbarren dafür ein dass mir jetzt kann
ich nur eine rettungsplattform oder als
allererstes das war der erste schritt
sei eine rettungsplattform und schwert
so schwert rettungsplattform ganz
wichtig mal vier denke ich vielleicht
noch daran dass sofort ihn
wahrscheinlich eher nicht aber es könnte
sein und auch eine perle und dann gucken
wir mal ob wir uns darüber ender perlen
könnten ich glaube überhaupt noch mal
schnell betrachte läuft aus oder man
stellt ein gebrochener mensch
geschwindigkeits zeigt normalen tempo
eines pete bocian hier so ok passt so
weit sagt auf der 44
hocke ich für die ganzen vier seid mir
nicht böse wenn es nicht klappt leute es
kann gut sein dass es nicht klappt ich
bin bekannt dafür dass ich ein bisschen
vergesslich bin
egal kommen über 4 444 444 alles klar
auch 4 auf 4 auf 4 es ist auf der 4
ich musste mich ja ja ich weiß ich weiß
ich kann gedrückt halten tut mir leid es
tut mir leid ich kann mich manchmal
nicht daran erinnern dass ich das machen
musst du schießt mich jetzt bitte nicht
von hinten ab müsste was für eine perle
einsetzen dass mit dass mir zu riskant
ich werde dich besteuerten japan sind
eigentlich schwieriger einzusetzen als
man denkt finde ich zumindest könnte man
die kommentare beim video das seht ich
finde dass die ender perlen gar nicht so
leicht einzusetzen sind wie man immer
denkt man muss schon ein bisschen drauf
achten gerade auf höhere distanz dass
man da wirklich gut wirft so ok den
franken nicht mehr nach jetzt geht's ab
jetzt geht's ab alles klar
so der letzte gegner und wir sind mega
gut ausgestattet wir können ihn holen
können wir überraschen kriegt überhaupt
mit dass weder karton
er hat mein bett er hat mein vater als
bei meinem alter schwede startet er sich
jetzt hierher
das könnte machen aber ich hab' sein
bett auch wo bist du jetzt wo bist du
jetzt sogar nova wo bist du
was war das okay ich habe auf einen
rekord aufgestellt 88 50 das war's von
heutigen folge bauer selbst euch
gewünscht
ich war heute ein bisschen matsch in der
birne keine ahnung wetter
frühjahrsmüdigkeit wie auch immer ich
hoffe trotzdem gefallen
das game doch noch und wir sehen uns
beim nächsten wieder drei macht's gut